et bien bonjour à toutes et tous ici
argueront que j'espère que vous allez
bien l'eau se retrouvent pour une petite
vidéo réaction ça faisait hyper en tant
qu'on n'en a pas fait une
parce que justement il ya le nouveau
trailer des animaux fantastiques pour le
deuxième opus qui va sortir le 14
novembre 2018 et du coup j'aimerais bien
qu'on voie ça ensemble du coup allons
voir ce trailer et je vais vous dire ce
que j'en pense donc c'est parti petite
vidéo comme ça donc à les écouter c'est
parti
[Musique]
j'ai des questions à vous poser
professeurs voilà une surprise
le bruit court que norbert dragon's
audois se rendre à paris
[Musique]
je sais qu'il travaille sous vos ordres
quelle explication avez-vous d'un bol
d'or
si vous aviez eu le plaisir d'être son
enseignant vous sauriez que norbert
n'est pas du genre à obéir au centre le
moment est venu norbert
de choisir ton corps
[Musique]
tu vas quelque part non nous allons
quelque part extra
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je ne peux pas m'en prendre à
grindelwald
il faut que ce soit vous
[Musique]
alors intéressant donc tâcher pas trop
quoi dire du coup donc nous voyons
dumbledore donc c'est vachement style et
donc qu'il ait joué par jude law donc il
ya pas mal de monde au casting on dirait
je reconnais plein de monde après je ne
saurais pas dire le nom de tous les
acteurs mais jude law du coup jouer
dumbledore joué par le judo donc cette
fois ça va se passer plus à poudlard
quelque chose d'intéressant c'est qu'on
avait pas vu poudlard dans le premier
opus alors je vous avoue que je n'ai je
suis pas un expert d'harry potter je
suis pas un expert des animaux
fantastiques jeu j'ai vu il ya longtemps
plus les animaux fantastiques mais
j'avoue que ce m
il peut bien ce qui m'a beaucoup
intrigué entre ailleurs ces convois
énormément de décors différents voit un
cirque on voit poudlard on voit une fête
hivernale à moitié une sorte de bal
dansant hivernale il ya l'air d'avoir
pleins pleins d'endroits ça risque
d'être une grande richesse au film c'est
ce qui me donne envie de le voir et en
même temps j'ai un peu peur j'ai
l'impression que ces genres surtout pour
le spectaculaire mais ça reste vraiment
intéressant et je pense que le film va
être vraiment bien et justement ce qui
m'a intrigué alors aussi on voit grendel
valent donc qu'ils aient joué par johnny
depp
c'est que du coup jude law
du coup d'un bol d'or ne dit à drago nos
qu'il ne peut pas dessus et grinder
grindelwald et que c'était lui le faire
et c'est là
que ça coince pour moi en fait
en fait j'adore harry potter mais un
truc qui m'énerve mais genre que j'ai
trouvé un petit peu abusé c'est que
dumbledore
il donne un bol d'eau reggae c'est pas
un problème mais il n'a jamais été
annoncé comme ça en fait ça a été
rajouté après pendant les causes à
moitié lgbt tout ça quand c'est ça se
faisait beaucoup parlé un moment j'ai
l'impression et et dumbledore est devenu
gay comme ça donc ça n'a jamais été
mentionné en fait j'ai trouvé que
c'était vachement une facilité comme ça
genre je vais créer une histoire et puis
tout d'un coup au final je vous dire
banamba lui léguait comme ça on se
change rien aux trucs mais c'est juste
que ça a été rajouté en fait juste pour
grindelwald j'ai l'impression alors
après je dis peut-être des conneries 1
mais apparemment dans mes souvenirs ça a
pas été mentionné dans les livres et
encore moins dans les films je pense au
prince de sang mêlé de fin dumbledore il
est à fond sur les filles à moitié nues
genre dans le film je m'en souviens mais
ouais c'est enfin ça me dérange pas non
plus mais c'est comme le coup de
hermione qui est devenu noir et
qu'apparemment elle a toujours été noir
dans les livres en fête s'est dit
qu'elle est blanche en fait cédé des
incohérences des facilités
scénaristiques en fait et j'ai
l'impression
cette facilité a juste été créé pour les
animaux fantastiques pour l'intrigué
pour que dumbledore bas en gros
grindelwald c'est son premier amour à
domme bol d'or et du coup voilà quoi fin
c'est juste des facilités scénaristiques
mois après ça change rien au film le
film je pense qu'il va être vraiment bon
il a l'air de ressembler pas mal au 1er
mai en plus à fond dans le côté harry
potter le premier poser les bases on
rencontrait dragon's les personnages
tout ça et grindelwald on le voit juste
à la fin et cette fois-ci là ça va être
plus j'ai l'impression dans le monde
d'harry potter liés au monde d'harry
potter on voit poudlard justement envoie
le le truc qui récupère les lumières
mais je sais plus le nom mais je crois
que il l'avait déjà dans le premier
anime à des animaux fantastiques mais
ouais je pense qu'il va être pas mal
donc on va voir moins de bêtes je pense
là je pense que ça est en fait une
histoire beaucoup plus tourné pape aux
fins non pas politique mais fait un
genre entre le bien et le mal quoi en
gros là il y aura pas de chasse 2
de chasse de bêtes ou et c'est ça être
vraiment poudlard des problèmes avec
dumbledore tout ça parce que c'est stylé
le voir dumbledore jeunes c est marrant
franchement je suis curieux parce que je
connais pas beaucoup de choses de
dumbledore quand il était jeune et je
sais que dans les films il fait pas mal
mention mais je n'ai pas lu les livres
et je sais que dans le livre j'aurais
appris plus de trucs mais c'est vrai que
je ne sais pas beaucoup de choses sur de
mulder jeunes du coup voilà en tout cas
il aura déjà la baguette de sureau
d'après ce que j'ai l'impression parce
qu'on a vu le signe et à la fin tu joues
le logo il ya même la baguette de sureau
alors je sais pas trop je me demande
mais je pense que dumbledore aura déjà
la baguette de sureau
alors ça c'est pareil je ne sais pas
comment il l'a acquise ou autre je sais
pas si c'est mentionné dans les livres
encore une fois je n'ai pas lu les
livres je suis pas potter elle je suis
pas non plus un gros gros fans d'harry
potter même si j'adore j'ai dit tous
regardé au moins 5,6 x et franchement
j'aime beaucoup à harry potter et les
animaux fantastiques je trouve peut-être
pas encore mieux mais je trouve que la
saga est bien frais et ça fait plaisir
est donc continuer dans le monde d'harry
potter avec d'autres histoires
j'espère que star wars ça va être ça
aussi c'est ce qui est prévu mais je
l'espère et que ça sera là aussi
grandiose que animaux fantastiques
en tout cas il va se passer plein de
choses je pense je sais pas trop quoi
vous dire de plus
je pense qu'il est peut-être possible
que je fasse un petit trois théories sur
le film il n'est pas il n'est pas
impossible
après ça vous de me dire dans les
commentaires si ça vous plairait les
amis et je le ferai avec plaisir si vous
le souhaitez donc voilà j'ai envie
d'avoir vos avis j'ai envie d'interagir
avec vous j'ai envie que vous me disiez
à chaque fois ci des sujets en fait que
vous aimeriez vraiment voir et là je
pense ça peut être une bonne idée de
sujet donc si vous voulez vraiment que
je fasse un trois théories sur les
animaux fantastiques 2 écoutez ce serait
avec plaisir et j'essaierai de faire mon
possible
bon bah écoutez moi je suis impatient
d'être au 14 novembre
j'ai pas que trop vous vous quoi vous
dire de plus donc merci à tous d'avoir
gardé cette petite vidéo n'hésitez pas à
liker à vous abonner et puis on se
retrouve
très prochainement c'était encore roque
et que le lie à 9 heures soit avec vous
[Musique]